president-elect joe biden is calling for
unity and healing
as america moves forward into our
national future
i'm just kidding he's trying to start a
race war no one can tell me
that it had been a group of black lives
matter protesting yesterday
there wouldn't have been they wouldn't
have been treated very very differently
than the mob of thugs that stormed the
capitol
well we all know that's true and it is
unacceptable
totally unacceptable the american people
saw a plain view
and i hope it's sensitized into what we
have to do
does this guy think we're stupid he does
i guess he does think that we're stupid
does he think that we don't remember the
last
six months when blm was permitted
to burn down sometimes government
buildings more often private buildings
to loot basically with impunity very few
people went to prison
and the few people that did go to prison
what happened joe biden's vice president
posted a fundraiser for their bail fund
so yeah probably they would have been
treated a little differently
had it been blm or antifa rather than
some trump supporters at the capitol a
couple of days ago
joe biden does this all the time though
you're going to hear the calls for unity
and healing and
it happens in the same breath they'll
say half the country is deplorably
irredeemable neo-nazis we need
healing and unity all these people
should be kicked off of social media and
not allowed to go back to their jobs
unity and healing and it's this this
endless
endless cycle but it's with biden
especially
he tries to put this focus on race you
know
if you really believed that the people
who stormed the capital
are neo-nazi white supremacists they
represent
70 million neo-nazi white supremacist
americans
who are on the verge of a civil war
that is largely on racial grounds if you
really believed that would you then
try to stoke racial tensions no of
course not
joe biden doesn't think we're on the
verge of a civil war joe biden just
thinks
stoking racial tensions is a good way to
score political points he's been doing
it for a long time do you remember
what was it eight eight nine years ago
now when joe biden
said that mitt romney met romney
as milk toast a liberal squish
republican
as you can possibly find such a liberal
squish
he invented obamacare such a liberal
squish that when he was running for
senate against teddy kennedy
he disavowed ronald reagan and george
bush
that guy so squishy but even he
nevertheless wanted to put black people
back in chains
according to joe biden look at what they
value
and look at their budget and what
they're proposing romney wants to let
the
he said in the first hundred days he's
gonna let the big banks once again write
their own rules
unchain wall street
they're gonna put you all back in chains
wants to put you all back in chains uh
unity and healing
yeah mitt romney every single republican
to the right of mitt romney namely
all of them and some democrats too yeah
they they support slavery yeah vote for
me unity and healing
joe biden is not the only one who is
doing this nancy pelosi doing this
as well president trump has what like 12
days or something left in his
term nancy pelosi is calling to remove
the president
immediately through the 25th amendment
yesterday the president of the united
states
incited an armed insurrection
against america the gleeful
desecration of the u.s capitol which is
the temple of amer
of our american democracy and the
violence targeting congress
are horrors that will forever stain our
nation's history
instigated by the president of the
united states
that's why it's such a stain in calling
for this seditious
act president has committed an
unspeakable assault
on our nation and our people
i joined the senate democratic leader in
calling on the vice president
to remove this president by immediately
invoking the 25th
amendment if the vice president and
cabinet do not act
the congress may be prepared to move
forward with impeachment
that is the overwhelming sentiment of my
caucus
oh well the overwhelming sentiment of
your caucus
and a buck 50 will get you a cup of
coffee because that's not the purpose of
the 25th amendment and absolutely
mike pence is not going to invoke it the
25th amendment is
a procedure for the removal of the
president should he be incapacitated
unable to discharge the duties of his
office
president trump is discharging the
duties of his office just fine
i know that nancy pelosi is very upset
about this but there is
absolutely talk about upsetting
constitutional norms and historical
precedent
there is absolutely no justification for
invoking the 25th amendment but then did
you hear what she says at the end
at the very end she says if not we're
going to move forward with impeachment
you people already tried that and it
didn't work because it was a completely
ginned up charge over nothing
and it was the fifth
iteration of the coup d'etat that
democrats had been trying to launch
since trump was campaigning and the
obama administration was spying on him
illegally after that they try to
well for one they colluded with a
foreign power namely russia to put
together
this bogus steel dossier to continue
their legal assault on trump
didn't go anywhere mueller investigation
didn't go anywhere
they cook up this ukraine thing didn't
go anywhere
they ignored the legitimate corruption
in ukraine from president-elect joe
biden
still doesn't go anywhere why would they
want impeachment
if if you really believe that that half
of this country supports donald trump
and
donald trump's a nazi so therefore half
the country is a bunch of nazis if you
really think
they're ready for armed insurrection
that's what they keep calling this
do you really think it will help the
cause of unity and healing
to to impeach and convict the president
of the united states
still popular with his base a dozen days
before he's supposed to leave office
no that will not heal a wound that will
exacerbate it that will
that will rip open a scab won't it
what would be the point of that well one
the democrats are
hoping to provoke the right so that they
can have further justification to clamp
down they're already doing it
they're de-platforming conservatives
in a very large scale which we'll get to
in a second
there's another procedural aspect to
this as to why the house would try to
impeach
president trump assuming assuming he
only gets this one term
president trump can still run again in
four years
and president trump has intimated that
he might run again in four years
if he is impeached and convicted he
can't run again in four years and so
there actually
is a long-term political benefit for
democrats
if even though you know as a practical
matter right now
he's not going to do anything in 10 days
but in the long term if they impeach and
convict him and right now they might
have the political will to do it
because a bunch of squishy republicans
are going to blame trump for
every evil that befalls the country and
they're going to they're going to blame
trump for the riot at the capitol and
they're going to completely ignore blm
and the
six months of rioting that burned down a
bunch of the country but they're just
going to focus on this one act as the
as the sole aspect of political violence
in the country even though frankly it is
a relatively
minor aspect given what we saw in 2020
still bad still unacceptable but
relatively
smaller than what we saw for the rest of
the year
and they'll try to convict him and that
way he won't run again
and what this says to me is they still
fear the guy
even after all of this after trump
self-inflicted wounds and there have
been many of them
and after every attack the democrats
have tried to lobby on him
they still fear this guy they fear that
he has a constituency
that the establishment republicans do
not
i think they they feel somewhat
similarly about josh hawley i think
that's why they're going after him
i think they feel similarly about ted
cruz i think that's why they're going
after him
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
you